and depending come in handy because a
lot of big artists
you know saying that we want to deal
with other big labels you know what i'm
saying uh if they already will you know
what i'm saying with a label
right so being independent is like you
can work with who you want
yeah like it's like it's it's less
easier for them like they can just
you know what i'm saying i was gonna say
you said something earlier that was
important
that we kind of glossed over and that
was that you're not having to go and
grab all the bags that you used to have
to grab
at the you know whatever city where you
pull up and do the club and [ __ ] but
at the time you're speaking from a
perspective of somebody who's
really been through most situations in
music because
you had a major type situation with
colombia right
and like you were saying you weren't
seeing money off off of the music
right you had pl and this is this is
somebody who's has
plaques yeah you have plaques you don't
know i had like
multiple like gold songs that's what i'm
saying and so for people who don't
understand like
most artists that you see that sign to
these majors and i ain't need to get
nothing but a damn 150
000 advance yeah and how did you not
recoup that
right that's crazy off of off of how
many gold records
two but that's insane just within that
two
or two years because i don't think i
don't think people understand like
when you get that you sign that record
deal you're gonna get that check right
but like from you better make that last
or you better start to build your merch
and your touring and all this [ __ ]
because
it's to be a while before you see money
from your actual music
that's why a lot of people just be
wondering like damn like you know what's
in
like how he doing he's like hey you know
what i'm saying
get this house i get this car like you
know what said he just got nick
just got in the game and all this i'm
just like bruh
like it's it's just different you feel
me a lot of people
most of the people that i know regular
major record deals like
wanting to get out you know what i'm
saying they hate it yeah they hate it
they're unhappy so
uh i just i just feel like it's just a
different like even
even with the major labels thing i ain't
even you know i'm not [ __ ] on that
situation it's just how people structure
they did because you could have an
independent type situation
with a major you know people people
don't know that it's just it's all about
leverage and lawyers
and if you're smart yeah you feel me and
you're not thirsty to get to like
because a lot of people see that
front-end check
and they're like yeah i ain't a lot like
them
a million dollars don't need people but
what your terms look like yeah only i
don't even get excited when i see deals
like
two million dollars no more and stuff
like that yeah i mean you went through
it like you said you took 150 thousand
dollar advance you had two gold records
and you're getting 35
checks yeah that's crazy
so that is crazy but that that happens
to a lot of people man
but you were smart enough to take your
money put it into investments and
you still got the tour bus that you
right now yeah yeah i'm using it on my
tour